[Música]
[Aplausos]
Vladimir Putin está obsesionado con los
libros de historia especialmente y
seguro que esto no sorprende a nadie con
todos aquellos que tratan sobre el
pasado Imperial de la madre patria Rusia
y ojo que no se trata solo de la lectura
en el kremlin y en general a lo largo y
ancho de toda Rusia Putin ha colocado
estatuas de históricos Monarcas como
Pedro el grande y Catalina La Grande y
esto queridos amigos amigas nos da
muchas pistas sobre lo que está
ocurriendo porque pues porque
precisamente estos dos Monarcas rusos
conquistaron para Rusia buena parte de
lo que hoy conocemos como Ucrania Claro
que Putin va mucho más allá para el
Ucrania es indiscutiblemente parte de
Rusia y por tanto su historia y sus
gentes Pues también lo son por ejemplo
en 2016 Justo a las puertas del kremlin
utimando levantar una estatua de
Vladimir el grande Un príncipe del
principado de kiev en el siglo X por
supuesto para Putin El príncipe de
Vladimir fue un Ruso de pura cepa de
hecho Ni más ni menos el ruso que abrazó
el cristianismo y completó el espíritu
nacional de lo que hoy es la madre Rusia
Así que no tiene ningún sentido hablar
de la historia de Ucrania de hecho el
propio Putin en el año 2008 le dijo al
presidente norteamericano de aquel
entonces George Bush Ucrania no es un
país real y en la víspera La cruel
invasión que desató la terrible guerra
que hoy estamos presenciando en
territorio ucraniano acusó al mismísimo
Vladimir Lenin de traicionar y destruir
el Imperio ruso al crear una nueva
República la República socialista
soviética de Ucrania bueno esas y otras
13 repúblicas además de Rusia y sabéis
que todo apunta a que el mismo se ve
como el líder el responsable de volver a
construir el Imperio ruso
exactamente en esta misma línea el 9 de
junio de 2022 en una reunión con jóvenes
empresarios Putin dijo dos cosas primero
que Ucrania no es ni será nunca un país
soberano incluso hablo de Colonia y
segundo se comparó con Pedro el grande
cuando este libro La gran guerra del
Norte contra Suecia durante 21 largos
años para devolverle a Rusia su grandeza
ahora bien un momento y estamos en
visualpolitik Y esto no es ninguna clase
de historia por supuesto la historia
puede jugar un papel muy importante pero
amigos amigas el pasado nunca puede ser
un límite al presente o al futuro Más
allá de si Ucrania fue o no parte de
Rusia o si sus habitantes hablan o no
ruso hoy es un país independiente y
soberano Exactamente igual que Estados
Unidos Australia Canadá o Irlanda los
son del Reino Unido su pasado como parte
del imperio británico y el hecho de que
hablen inglés no le da Londres ningún
derecho histórico sobre ellos pero al
líder ruso Todo esto le da Exactamente
igual
[Música]
en 2021 publicó un tratado de unas 5000
palabras sobre la unidad histórica de
rusos y ucranianos un tratado en el que
Putin defiende que rusos bielorrusos y
ucranianos forman un mismo pueblo bajo
que ahora Moscú tiene que volver a
integrar por las buenas o por las malas
y eso es exactamente lo que intentó el
día 24 de febrero cuando lanzó lo que
pensaba sería una rápida exitosa y
gloriosa invasión de Ucrania
Claro que como todos sabemos lo que
ocurrió entonces Fue totalmente
diferente Putin ahora mismo ya no tiene
la oportunidad de ser el constructor del
nuevo imperio ruso sino más bien el
responsable de hundir a la patria su
Campaña en ucraniana ha destrozado al
ejército ruso que ahora va de derrota en
derrota e incluso ha perdido el buque
insignia de la armada en el mar Negro
para colmo ahora está en camino de
hundir también la economía nacional Así
que podemos decir que Vladimir Putin se
está convirtiendo en el peor enemigo de
la ambición Imperial rusa el desastre
está siendo tan grande que de unos
190.000 efectivos que componían la
fuerza de Invasión inicial Las bajas
entre muertos y heridos se calculan en
unas 100.000 el ejército ruso ha tenido
un rendimiento peor de lo que jamás
hubiera imaginado es demasiado pronto
para planear un desfile de la Victoria
aquí pero creo que los ucranianos están
a punto de lograr un impulso
Irreversible mientras nosotros occidente
sigamos estando con ellos generan
retirado
del ejército de Estados Unidos en Europa
un buen ejemplo de lo que está siendo la
guerra lo tenemos en la estratégica
ciudad de kupians a orillas del río
skill una importante encrucijada de
ferrocarriles y carreteras
[Música]
Pues bien durante 195 días esta ciudad
no sólo vivió bajo la ocupación rusa
sino que se convirtió en uno de los
centros más importantes de la
Administración militar rusa por aquí
pasaban y se organizaban los suministros
críticos a las líneas del frente Era uno
de los fortines claves en la maquinaria
de guerra de Moscú y sin embargo pese a
ello el 10 de septiembre del 2022 la
nonagésima segunda brigada mecanizada de
Ucrania capturó esta ciudad e hizo
volver a las banderas Azules y amarillas
increíble pero cierto
[Música]
otro ejemplo pues ahí tenemos el caso de
gersón la ciudad se llenó de carteles
que decían que la ciudad sería rusa para
siempre Incluso como luego veremos Rusia
es el anexionó junto a la mayor parte de
loblas Sin embargo pese a la anexión a
los carteles y a todo el anunciado ocho
meses después de ocuparla los rusos
tuvieron que retirarse y la ciudad ha
vuelto a ser ucraniana
pero como os decía lo peor para Rusia
puede estar por llegar las sanciones
internacionales están dañando su
economía el tope al precio del petróleo
puede terminar por hundir los ingresos
del gobierno muchos jóvenes han
fallecido en la guerra o están escapando
de Rusia y muchos países están ya
suspendiendo grandes contratos con la
industria nacional por ejemplo Indonesia
y filipinas han anulado grandes
contratos militares con la industria
rusa en el caso de Indonesia hablamos de
un contrato multimillonario para la
compra de caza su coi 35 aviones que
usarán reemplazados por equipos
franceses y norteamericanos
Indonesia compra aviones de combate
estadounidenses y franceses por valor de
22.000 millones de dólares el sujoy 35
ruso perdió el cambio de rumbo de
Indonesia que ha pasado de un acuerdo
con Rusia a nuevos acuerdos de compra
con Estados Unidos y Francia pone de
manifiesto La potencia de las sanciones
estadounidenses y ahí No termina todo
además la posición internacional es cada
vez más delicada
sin ir más lejos una comisión de
investigación del Consejo de derechos
humanos de Naciones Unidas ha publicado
un durísimo informe que acusa a la
federación rusa de cometer múltiples
crímenes de guerra durante la invasión
hablamos de ejecuciones torturas
violaciones Y por supuesto el constante
bombardeo de zonas e infraestructuras
civiles es decir el relato ruso hace
aguas por todas partes y para colmo el
frente de cada día está peor si los
ucranianos siguen empujando y la ayuda
occidental continúa llegando Rusia se
arriesga a sufrir una catastrófica
derrota lo que podría suponer el propio
final de Vladimir Putin Y ante esta
situación hay una pregunta que se ha
propagado A los cuatro vientos estará
Rusia dispuesta a escalar el conflicto y
llegado el caso utilizar armas nucleares
podría esto cambiar el rumbo de la
guerra puede el kremlin lograr un
acuerdo de paz que le permita lavar la
cara pues bien veámoslo
la última bala
el día 30 de septiembre del 2022 el
presidente ruso firmó la incorporación a
la federación rusa de los oblats
ucranianos de luans taporicha y kerson
fue al menos formalmente la mayor toma
forzosa de territorio en toda Europa
desde la Segunda Guerra Mundial
podríamos decir que el objetivo de Putin
con esta anexión era demostrarle al
pueblo ruso que la guerra estaba
teniendo algún sentido que lejos de
producirse una derrota Rusia estaba
ganando territorio El problema es que ni
siquiera Esto está ocurriendo
exactamente así es cierto que Rusia no
ha delimitado el territorio que se ha
anexionado lo cual parece una broma de
mal gusto pero aún así las ofensivas
ucranianas en gerson y la expulsión de
las tropas rusas al este del río nieper
ha resultado humillante si la propaganda
rusa le vendió al mundo y también a los
propios rusos Sería para siempre una
ciudad rusa hoy ya no lo es y ojo que
esto es importante porque tras la
anexión y desde el punto de vista ruso
claro las ofensivas ucranianas están
dirigiendo ya contra el propio
territorio de Rusia y Qué significa esto
pues teóricamente y con las propias
reglas del kremlin ahora Moscú está
perdiendo la guerra en casa por tanto ya
no se puede hablar de una operación
especial
y el problema queridos amigos amigas es
que Vladimir Putin es como un jugador
adicto al Poker que siempre siempre sube
su apuesta esa ha sido al menos la
experiencia hasta ahora a pesar de estar
perdiendo todas las partidas y sabéis
que esto es algo que ha hecho saltar
muchas alarmas 2 de noviembre de 2022
dice que está preparando 425 refugios en
caso de un ataque nuclear ruso
acorralado humillado Derrotado cambiar
el curso de la guerra parece
prácticamente imposible pero podría el
régimen de Putin intentar un ataque
nuclear que obliga a occidente y a la
propia Ucrania negociar un alto el fuego
podría el kremlin llevar al extremo
nuclear su presión para que la guerra
termine Ya y así Putin pueda venderle a
los rusos las conquistas logradas y ojo
que no hablamos de ninguna hipótesis
irracional
Rusia ha destrozado Sí su ejército en
Ucrania Pero sigue teniendo una
fortaleza su enorme Arsenal nuclear y no
hablamos ya de las grandes bombas
nucleares capaces de arrasar ciudades y
regiones al completo sino de su arsenal
de cerca de 2.000 armas nucleares
tácticas de entre 1 y 10 kilotones armas
Por lo general mucho más pequeñas que
nunca empleado en combate pero que
fueron diseñadas no para arrasar una
ciudad sino para enfrentarse a un
ejército convencional en el campo de
batalla un Arsenal que Putin y los altos
gerifaltes del kremlin podrían
plantearse utilizar en un momento de
desesperación como golpe de fuerza
tenemos nuestro propio potencial militar
si alguien piensa que no lo usaremos si
una amenaza grave entonces se equivoca
Dimitri no vicepresidente del comité de
relaciones exteriores de la duma
imaginemos que Rusia se ve obligada a
usar sus armas más formidables contra el
régimen ucraniano que ha cometido un
acto de agresión a gran escala que está
poniendo en peligro la existencia misma
de nuestro estado creo que la otan no
interferirá directamente en el conflicto
ni siquiera en ese escenario Dimitri
diputado el propio Putin amenazó por
primera vez con usar armas nucleares
justo al comienzo de la invasión fijaos
Rusia sigue teniendo uno de los estados
nucleares más poderosos además tiene
cierta ventaja en varias armas de
vanguardia en este contexto no debería
haber ninguna duda para nadie de que
cualquier agresor potencial se
enfrentará la derrota y a consecuencia
ominosas si ataca directamente a nuestro
país Vladimir Putin y con la llegada del
otoño y los grandes reveses en el campo
de batalla las amenazas del kremlin se
multiplicaron y ojo porque esto es
exactamente lo que explica noticias como
esta 10 de noviembre de 2022 El general
de mayor Rango de Estados Unidos instala
diplomacia en Ucrania mientras los
asesores de vaivén se resisten el
general Mark Miley jefe del Estado Mayor
conjunto ha defendido que los ucranianos
deben intentar consolidar sus logros en
la mesa de negociaciones 23 de noviembre
de 2022 guerra en Ucrania Emanuel macron
anuncia que tendrá contacto directo con
Vladimir Putin en los próximos días los
importantes avances ucranianos que han
puesto a Rusia contra las cuerdas han
hecho que por primera vez se
multipliquen las presiones para que se
negoció alto el fuego y así el conflicto
no siga escalando Y es que la pregunta
es si Rusia está perdiendo la guerra por
qué demonios no echar mano de su Arsenal
nuclear Pues bien queridos amigos amigas
Lo cierto es que existen seis buenas
razones por las que es poco probable que
Rusia utilice su Arsenal nuclear O mejor
dicho seis buenos motivos por las que
recurrir a las armas nucleares sería un
tremendo error para Rusia atentos
[Música]
el disparate nuclear
utilizar un arma nuclear para evitar la
derrota en Ucrania puede tener cierto
sentido hasta que esta cuestión se
analiza con tranquilidad lo cierto Es
que existen buenas razones para pensar
que Moscú no utilizará armas nucleares
en Ucrania en concreto podemos destacar
seis grandes motivos primero existen
mejores alternativas militares me
explico en caso de recurrir al uso de
armas nucleares para dar un golpe en la
mesa la opción lógica sería el uso de
armas nucleares tácticas contra el
ejército ucraniano sin embargo frente a
lo que podríamos pensar el uso de estas
armadas supondría escalar el conflicto
sin conseguir probablemente ninguna
ventaja militar
[Música]
las armas nucleares tácticas equipan por
lo general ojivas pequeñas que fueron
ideadas para atacar fuerzas de combate
numerosas y concentradas pero el
ejército ucraniano no opera con gran
concentración de fuerzas y además está
en constante movimiento con lo cual los
daños serían limitados de hecho para las
armas por debajo de los 10 kilotones sus
efectos son superados por la artillería
de alta precisión y las armas
termobáricas que ya se han utilizado en
el frente
de esta forma derrotar la capacidad
militar de Ucrania requeriría del uso de
docenas y docenas de armas nucleares
tácticas por ejemplo en los planes del
ejército de Estados Unidos durante la
Guerra Fría si contemplaba emplear 136
bombas nucleares tácticas para limpiar
un frente de 100 km y el frente actual
entre Ucrania y Rusia se extiende a lo
largo de más de 600 sus armas nucleares
son más útiles para ellos cuando no las
usan Simplemente no hay ninguna ventaja
en el campo de batalla por usar un arma
nuclear género retirado
del ejército de Estados Unidos en Europa
por supuesto Estas armas podrían ser
útiles para atacar eléctricas e
infraestructuras pero su empleo tendría
muchas más consecuencias sin marcar
ninguna diferencia y esto nos lleva
directamente al segundo motivo
[Música]
el uso de armas nucleares no supondría
al final del problema para Rusia sino
más bien todo lo contrario sería el fin
de la solución y es que veréis el uso de
armas nucleares de cualquier calibre
conllevaría una rotunda condena
internacional una condena mucho mayor
que la causada por la propia guerra
digamos que la presión contra Rusia
sería tan grande que las sanciones se
generalizarían por todo el mundo
incluyendo sanciones secundarias querían
que países relativamente amistosos como
la India o emiratos árabes pues dejarán
de serlo la presión occidental
alcanzarían niveles inimaginables y
Rusia se convertiría en un país
radiactivo nunca Mejor dicho algo así
como una nueva Corea del Norte lo que
por supuesto sería fatal para los
ciudadanos rusos y para los propios
oligarcas y jeriales del país que ya no
encontrarían refugio
incluso países como china ya han dejado
Claro que eso sería una línea roja Por
qué pues porque si Rusia usa armas
nucleares la no proliferación sería
hacer puñetas muchos países del sudeste
asiático se lanzarían de lleno a
desarrollar sus propias armas nucleares
como seguro de vida y todo ello para que
Rusia no consiga una Clara ventaja
militar
pero no solo Hablamos de una reacción
política o económica sino también quizás
de una militar Washington ha sido muy
claro el uso de armas nucleares
conllevaría una respuesta contundente
por parte de occidente Esto es algo que
tanto el Secretario de Defensa como el
jefe del Estado Mayor conjunto El
general Mark Miller o el asesor de
seguridad nacional se han encargado de
trasladar a los altos gerifaltes rusos
hemos comunicado directamente en privado
a niveles muy altos al kremlin que
cualquier uso de armas nucleares tendría
consecuencias catastróficas para Rusia
que Estados Unidos y nuestros aliados
responderán con decisión y hemos sido
claros y específicos sobre lo que eso
implicaría Jake Sullivan asesor de
seguridad Nacional de la casa blanca y a
ver no sabemos exactamente a qué tipo de
respuesta se refiere Sullivan pero lo
que se ha filtrado es que en caso de un
ataque nuclear la otan respondería con
un ataque convencional a gran escala
para destruir las fuerzas rusas en
Ucrania y garantizar así la soberanía de
este país
otra posible respuesta podría ser
entregarle Ucrania equipos mucho más
avanzados y letales por ejemplo equipos
de ataque a larga distancia o incluso
toda una fuerza aérea y visto lo visto
está claro que de producirse esta
respuesta el resultado directo podría
ser la aniquilación de todas las fuerzas
rusas en Ucrania hasta donde sabemos
Putin está amenazando con usar armas
nucleares tácticas en suelo ucraniano no
para atacar a la otan lo que significa
que la otan debe responder de una manera
convencional pero la respuesta Debería
ser devastadora Y supongo que este es el
mensaje Claro que la alianza de la otan
está enviando a Rusia en este momento es
biknivez ministro de asuntos exteriores
de Polonia y bueno Todos hemos visto lo
que ha ocurrido con el ejército
convencional a priori Rusia debería
haber Derrotado rápidamente Ucrania pero
la corrupción la falta de equipos las
carencias de entrenamiento y el pobre
mantenimiento han hecho que la guerra
sea una pesadilla Pues bien seamos
claros es poco probable que las armas
nucleares de Rusia estén en mucho mejor
estado que sus fuerzas convencionales y
os imagináis lo que supondría un error o
un fallo en el uso de Estas armas podría
ser el golpe de Gracia para el kremlin
incluso podría terminar dañando a su
propio ejército y ojo que esto no es una
posibilidad Rusia es un país en el que
encontramos noticias como esta ladrones
roban el equipo de radio del avión ruso
del día del juicio final unos ladrones
han robado equipos electrónicos de un
avión militar ruso conocido como avión
del juicio final por su papel en el
Arsenal nuclear del país informan los
medios locales y por supuesto existe el
riesgo de que la escalada fuera
exponencial Este es el quinto motivo
desde la Guerra Fría se tuvo Claro que
las armas nucleares eran artefactos de
disuasión no de agresión el empleo de
armas nucleares podría terminar
provocando daños inimaginables para
todos Ese fue el equilibrio de la
destrucción mutua asegurada en el que se
han formado los propios rusos todos
ellos son conscientes de las
consecuencias y por supuesto todos
tienen familias y amigos y de hecho eso
hace que el empleo de armas nucleares
tampoco sea algo Popular en casa por
ejemplo Igor ivanovich strelkoff un
líder paramilitar que fue clave en la
toma de crimea y en la guerra del compás
ha dejado claro que el uso de armas
nucleares sería un error e incluso un
crimen Este es el sexto motivo Pues bien
todas estas razones explican por qué
nunca se han vuelto a utilizar armas
nucleares no ocurrió ni la guerra de
Corea ni la guerra de Vietnam ni en la
ocupación soviética de Afganistán ni
tampoco la propia Guerra de Ucrania a
pesar de que Rusia ha perdido ya a
decenas de miles de hombres las
consecuencias podrían ser tan graves que
incluso Aunque Putin perdiera la cabeza
el incentivo a frenarle sería muy grande
y sí evidentemente si algo nos enseña la
historia es que la realidad puede
terminar superando cualquier escenario
probable pero amigos amigas Más allá del
mundo de los dementes es poco probable
que Rusia eche mano de su Arsenal
nuclear sea como sea el problema que
Ucrania no se puede permitir una salida
en falso un acuerdo de paz sin sesiones
por parte de Rusia podría condenar de
forma permanente este país y eso es algo
que los ucranianos difícilmente
aceptarán pero llegado hasta aquí turno
para ti crees que la Rusia de Putin se
atreverá a usar armas nucleares crees
que el fin de la guerra puede estar
próximo déjanos como siempre tus
impresiones en los comentarios y
hablamos debate y ahora si este vídeo se
ha resultado interesante No olvides
darle a like y suscribiros si es que aún
no lo habéis hecho una vez más Muchas
gracias por estar ahí un saludo y hasta
la próxima
[Música]